this is tomorrow same standing info
reviewer Richard weakling the first game
I played in dreams was a cute captain
told inspired puzzle platformer called
pip gem Walker
it's about a sloth who has to collect
hidden gems across seven increasingly
complex levels the second game I played
was blade gunner a resogun style twin
stick shooter with upgrades and in-game
store and online leaderboards after that
I hopped into art therapy a first-person
game where your goal as a disgruntled
artist wielding a baseball bat is to
smash your way through a museum without
any of the gods catching you in the act
each of these games is vastly different
from the loss not just in terms of the
genre and gameplay mechanics but their
use or disuse of cutscenes voice acting
art style music narrative and so on
the one thing that each have in common
is that they were all created using the
exact same set of tools that streams in
a nutshell a platform where you can
create pretty much anything you can put
your mind to whether these creations
take the form of an hour-long video game
a short film a simple visual spectacle
or something as simple as a sound effect
that other players can use in their own
project the possibilities are endless
which I know is a tired cliché but in
dreams more than anywhere else it
actually applies
next stop cowboy town please alight here
for the mines there are two parts the
dreams dream shaping is where you can
begin creating your own projects and
find tutorials that will teach you how
dream surfing is where you find other
people's creations and play them for
yourself it's also where you'll find
arts dream this is for lack of a better
term develop a Media Molecule zone story
mode or campaign what makes it so
fascinating however is that the two-hour
long game was made entirely using the
same creation tools available to
everyone else the fact that dreams is
toaster allows for the creation of
something like arts dream is genuinely
incredible but it's also a touching and
melancholic tale that's completely
different to any story Media Molecule
has told before the narrative centers on
a troubled double bass player who quit
his band and alienated all of his
friends leading to a life of regrets
it's not quite as depressing as it
sounds meshing the more dour notes with
plenty of hopefulness charm and that
Media Molecule whimsy but it is a
notably mature tale for the studio it's
also a statement and a promise of what's
achievable in dreams
[Music]
that's not to say you'll be creating
something as complex and grandiose as
art stream within a couple of days
months or even a year the dream shaping
creation suite is initially a daunting
proposition with the freedom to create
anything you can put your mind to the
tool set has to be exhaustive to
compensate
so your first gander into dream shaping
is guaranteed to be overwhelming
fortunately the dreams workshop is
chock-full of informative tutorials that
run through each tall and fundamental
technique that's available to you there
are beginner classes that focus on the
basics of edit mode from getting you
accustomed with its control scheme to
teaching you how to place platforms
resize objects and clone items the
control scheme is definitely a sticking
point though there are three to choose
from but none of them are specially
intuitive navigating around a 3d
environment with the left and right
sticks while using motion controls to
move a cursor initially feels cumbersome
particularly when you're trying to be
precise and hone in on the finer details
the PlayStation Move controllers fare
slightly better when it comes to
sculpting mainly because it feels much
more natural to mold and shape objects
with your hands the move control scheme
does come with its own unwieldy nuances
however giving the DualShock an
advantage for navigating menus and
controlling the camera which in turn
makes designing levels are slightly more
fluid experience as a whole
whichever control scheme you choose the
mixture of imperfect motion controls and
imperfect regular controls does present
an additional learning curve the more
you get used to them the more
comfortable they become but it does take
a while to grasp other tutorials delve
into more specific areas of game design
with step by step guides to painting and
coloring tutorials on how to animate
characters and objects by hand and how
to videos that teach you how to quickly
assemble a level amongst other
techniques beyond this our advanced
intermediate and master class tutorials
that teach you how to create your own
original music and sound or run through
how to assemble connectors and use
physics learning it all means devoting a
significant amount of time so it's good
that the tutorials are incredibly
helpful and enlightening the toolset is
streamlined compared to unity or Unreal
Engine in order to make the creation
sweet slightly more accessible for your
average Joe but the tutorials provide a
greater appreciation for how challenging
game development truly is they also
maintain dreams as focus on creativity
actively encouraging you to express
yourself even when learning how the tool
sets were
this makes working your way through each
tutorial and enjoyable experience when
tutorials can so often be a drag when it
comes to creating your own project
dreams gives you the flexibility to ease
yourself in because not every piece of
it has to be wholly your own Media
Molecule has numerous presets for you to
choose from but other players can also
upload their own creations whether it's
an entire environment a single character
or a piece of music which you can then
download and use in your own creations
this establishes a tangible sense of
community that bleeds into every other
aspect of dreams from dream shaping to
dream surfing and it's this community
centric approach that inspires me to
learn and create more the simple act of
making stuff is also just enjoyable to
do there's a tactile feeling to using
the various paint strokes or object
molding that's satisfying to play around
with grabbing and pulling at a sculpture
to establish a shape before using facial
features from the community to devise an
unorthodox character the way you create
sound and music is similarly freeform
with the option of loading up a pre-made
virtual instrument that you can then
play around with using basic button
inputs I may not know the first thing
about music composition or sound design
but I've listened to enough to know how
to create a rudimentary tune the tool
sets intuitiveness just makes it
possible obviously
designing an entire game with mechanics
that actually work is a challenging
process but the ease with which you can
simply jump in and make objects and
sounds ensures that creation suite is
engaging to use even when you're just
messing around on the flip side you can
always ignore the creation side
completely and fall down the rabbit hole
or playing other people's work dreams is
like YouTube for video games where a
single hour can take you on a journey
through so many disparate and
imaginative experiences
there are the usual imitators with
myriad recreations of levels from the
likes of Sonic the Hedgehog Metal Gear
Solid and crash bandicoot but there's
also a value in seeing these familiar
characters environments and mechanics
recreated because it offers an easy way
to gauge what the tour set is capable of
the majority are original creations
however and it's their sheer diversity
that really stands out one of my
personal favorites is dogs run a game
where you get to play as the creator's
own pet dog binky it's a classic
platforming collectathon like banjo
kazooie but I found it oddly
heartwarming because of its furry
protagonists it actually inspired me to
try and improve my non-existence
skills in the creation suite just so I
can one day immortalize my own dog in
dreams finding each of these games is
relatively simple thanks to media
molecules beautiful curation of the
dream surfing area the homepage includes
trending creations favorites picked by
Media Molecule itself and
recommendations based on your play
history if you're not sure what to play
you can hit auto serve and be
transported directly into a random game
or if you want to search for something
specific there's a robust search engine
that lets you find what you're looking
for with a few simple keywords Media
Molecule has made it so you can
effortlessly hop from one game or
singular experience to another and
discover something worthwhile Dreamz was
in early access for less than a year but
the small community it's built since
then has already created some stunning
projects that exhibit imagination
innovation and art history now that the
full game is out in the wild it's going
to be fascinating to see how the
community continues to grow and what
creations arise from that growth Media
Molecule has devised something really
special with Dreamz placing a hefty
toaster in players hands where the only
limitations are your skills imagination
and time there's nothing else quite like
it and it feels like the culmination of
everything the studio has been working
towards since the very first
LittleBigPlanet the presentation is
charming while the tutorials are
informative active and engaging playing
and finding other people's creations
meanwhile is a breeze Dreamz is a
refined constructor for building a wide
variety of games and a community centric
showcase where others can play them it's
a stunning achievement that encourages
limitless creative expression a place
where people can come together
collaborate and explore each other's
imaginations it's a tool for the Falls
who dream and one of the most innovative
releases in years
[Music]
you